[Music]
you're giving me a little bit of Britney
today no I'm so you're the first one
that noticed I got had to tell everyone
else but no I definitely wanted to
channel Britney we're having an oops
moment we are oops I did it again well
what are you most looking forward to in
there today is it predictable today
Britney true of you know I'm honest Sam
so I'm so excited to perform on this
stage feels like home just the way
[Music]
are we working on new music already yeah
we well we just announced my summer tour
detour it starts in July and I'm going
all around us I leave tonight for my
European tour so I'm very very excited
it's been such an incredible experience
but I've been writing like crazy so
there's gonna be a lot of new things
this summer and you can expect that on
tour what's one of the influences right
now what I think a lot of the just
confident strong voices Rihanna Beyonce
you've got so many powerful and so much
personality within them and their music
and then you know also ed Sheeran and
Bruno Mars and just kind of changing a
lot of things up and yeah I love all of
it now we're just gonna be solely
focused on music now because Girl Meets
World has wrapped yeah are we gonna go
back into acting yes right yeah Girl
Meets World is wrapped in no it's
definitely not um luckily you can do
both and I'm super excited to tell
everybody would have been up to I can't
right now but I'm definitely still both
in the works there's some stuff in the
works well with Rome each world were you
at least okay happy with how things
wrapped up you know what we it hasn't
changed because we all are still so
close we were really lucky didn't got to
do three seasons so many shows don't so
we were we were very lucky look at the
bright side you have no choice yes
you